the draft a week away the odds have
changed
yet again for the third overall pick in
the draft chris you moved the market a
few weeks ago when you went heavy with
mac
jones the third overall pick for the san
francisco 49ers
and then what happened justin fields had
his pro day two
and it went the other way well now mac
jones the favorite
once again at minus 140
to be i think that second column may be
off a little bit
no it's not there was another there was
another step there was another step
there was another step in between where
fields was the favorite my bad that's
not on that graphic but now
jones is the favorite again a week ago
fields was the favorite in minus
territory
now mac jones back in minus territory at
140 fields at plus 130
and there's trey lance whose odds
actually have gotten better since that
last one i think he was plus 425 the one
that's not on the graphics so
i look i don't think i i still think
they went up there we talked about this
yesterday knowing who it was going to be
and it's just guesswork for the rest of
us to figure it out and
for whatever reason last week the
guesswork as it relates to the money
people were putting on those
wagers pushed the thing toward fields
being the favorite
now it's back where i think it should
have been all along mac jones should be
the favorite
based upon the analysis that you and
others attached to that move that was
made
last month by the 49ers up the number
yeah i mean again again
i'd be shocked if it's not mac jones i
really would be i mean that was my
original thought from the get-go
you know and and like i've said many
times
listen you know kyle shanahan is really
smart
he's really well thought out he really
is this is not something i think he just
dove into or flipped a coin and was like
i'm trading up to number three everybody
you know i think this was like you're
saying a tactical move
with having one guy in mind but also
going
wait i like the whole group here really
they're all talented guys let me look at
them blah blah blah and i'm going to
continue to do my homework
but i really like this one guy and
that's why i'm really trading up to get
them
so we'll see where that goes we will i
mean there's certainly really
interesting things about all three of
these guys games
they have some elite traits but to me
i'll go back to my base thought
once again only one of those three guys
that we put on that graphic is
nfl ready right now ready to play
execute any offense other than the lamar
jackson offense and that's mack jones
and to me
you don't trade up to get a guy that got
a few like oh
i i think he can fix this oh i think
he'll be able to do this
oh i need to work at him in this area oh
i need to sit him out for a year
that's not who you trade up to number
three for in my opinion and that's why i
would continue to think it's mac jones
and i continue to believe you don't make
that pick unless you're damn sure who
it's going to be
yeah you're trading for the guy not for
the slot
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports